ses larmes utilisé par marc lépine pour
tuer les quatorze étudiante de
polytechnique
trente ans plus tard le google min 14
est toujours légale au canada c'est
vraiment triste qu'après 30 à ce terme
là demeure une âme non restreintes donc
celle qui est le moins contrôlés
d'autres pays ont pourtant banni les
armes semi automatiques qui ont servi à
des tueurs lors de fusillades
comme en nouvelle zélande à la suite de
la tragédie de christchurch en mars
dernier au japon si c'est totalement
interdit en australie où on perd mais
pas les armes longues qui ont plus que
deux projets de munitions dans le
système de tir les libéraux sous
chrétien avait promis de l'intérieur à
et pourtant il en fait le gouvernement
trudeau s'engage à son tour à bannir
cette âme école polytechnique pour y
parvenir
ottawa devra revoir sa loi en profondeur
croire francis langlois
s'ils veulent interdire ce type d'armes
la langue des fusils d'assaut
essentiellement ils doivent absolument
modifier la loi donc non plus
catégoriser les armes à feu en fonction
de la gare du canon mais les catégoriser
en fonction des caractéristiques donc
dès qu'on a une arme semi automatique
avec un chargeur détachable par exemple
mais voilà c'est juste des armes
d'assaut donc on an les seuls les
militants pro armes
euh pas plutôt qu'il faut mieux encadrer
le permis de possession et acquisitions
d'armes à feu au lieu de juste attendre
dans le renouvellement ou cinq ans on
serait capable de faire des
vérifications des vérifications soient
allés à 3 ou soit une fois par année
chez propriétaire faire leur inventaire
heidi rathjen elle a bon espoir que ces
termes qui a tué ses consoeurs soit
finalement interdite
ici marie-eve cousineau radio canada
montréal